اعلنت هيئه عمليات التجاره البحريه
البريطانيه قبل قليل عن تلقيها بلاغا عن
حادثه على بعد 57 ميلا بحريا غربي الحديده
في اليمن نذهب مباشره الى الحديده معنا من
هناك مراسلنا سمير النمري هل من تحديثات
سمير نعم سلم حتى هذه اللحظه لم تعلن
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين عن عمليه
الاستهداف التي اعلنت عنها هيئه العمليات
البحريه
البريطانيه وفي العاده يعلن الناطق
العسكري باسم جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
عن اي عمليه استهداف للسفن الامريكيه
والبريطانيه وكذلك السفن التجاريه
المتوجهه الى اسرائيل في وقت لاحق من هذا
اليوم لكن سلمى كان هناك تطورات مرتبطه
بهذا الموضوع من قبل حيث شنت طيران
الامريكي والبريطاني بحسب وسائل اعلاميه
تابعه لانصار الله عدد من الغارات الجويه
على محافظتي الحديده وكذلك صعده استهدفت
مواقع عسكريه تقول الجماعه انها مواقع
كانت مخله من الجنود والمعدات وانها لا
توجد تاثيرات او اضرار بشريه وماديه على
تلك المعسكرات هذا هذه العمليات تاتي بعد
اعلان جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين استهداف
سفينه شحن ع امريكيه مسماه بكول كانت تبحر
في خليج عدن ووفق الناطق العسكري لانصار
الله فقد تم استهدافها بصواريخ مباشره
بصواريخ نوعيه مباشره وان الاستهداف كان
مباشر في السفينه و كذلك الاحداث تاتي
ايضا في ظل تطورات تشهدها منطقه البحر
الاحمر وخليج عدن والبحر العربي مع
استمرار استهداف عدد من السفن العسكريه
الامريكيه والتي تقول الولايات المتحده
انها تقوم باسقاط عدد من الصواريخ
البالستيه المتوجهه نحو المدمرات
الامريكيه بينما تقول جماعه انصار الله ان
الاستهداف دائما يتم بشكل مباشر نحن اليوم
في انتظار كلمه او خطاب مرتقب لزعيم
الجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين عبد الملك
الحوثي من المحتمل ان يعلن فيه عن مالات
المرحله القادمه فيما ستقوم الجماعه
باستمرار تصعيدها العسكري ضد القوات
الامريكيه
والبريطانيه او اعلان نتائج جديده لعملي
شكرا لك سمير النمري مراسلنا من الحديده